correspondante ce n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour officiel mais il sera évidemment
question du coup du coup de force de
Wagner le week-end dernier là en effet
la rébellion de Wagner devrait même
dominer ces discussions sur l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui lors de ce sommeil européen
à Bruxelles dans un dernier projet de
conclusion qui circule les 27 pourrait
se mettre d'accord sur des engagements
de sécurité vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine c'est
un paragraphe qui a été ajouté à la
demande de la France mais qui inquiète
certains États membres comme l'Autriche
par exemple qui n'est pas membre de
l'OTAN et qui est militairement neutre
l'autre sujet qui devrait beaucoup
occupé les 27 aujourd'hui c'est la
question des actifs gelés russes vous
savez cela fait un moment qui est évoqué
l'idée d'utiliser les rendements de ses
actifs gelés pour financer la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine mais c'est
un mécanisme qui est très difficile à
mettre en place juridiquement et puis
certains s'inquiète aussi du signal que
cela pourrait envoyer au marché
financier donc même si la Commission
européenne semble très volontaire sur
cette question ça reste une idée
difficile à mettre en place allez un
autre sujet l'actualité qui sera
également à l'ordre du jour c'est celui
de l'immigration en effet impossible
pour les 27 défis d'éviter ce sujet de
la migration après ce naufrage meurtrier
en Méditerranée et au vu des chiffres
d'entrée illégales sur le sol de l'Union
européenne qui sont vous le savez en
augmentation alors début juin les 27 se
sont mis d'accord sur un certain nombre
de textes mais qui ont plutôt avoir avec
la gestion interne de la migration
aujourd'hui il va être question de
parler de la gestion externe de ces
migrations c'est-à-dire tous ces projets
d'accord avec des pays de transit on se
souvient en 2016 de l'accord passé avec
la Turquie pour que le pays garde sur
son sol les réfugiés syriens et bien
aujourd'hui il y a aussi des projets
d'accord avec des pays comme le Maroc et
la Tunisie des accords gagnants gagnants
selon des sources internes ici à
Bruxelles puisqu'en l'échange d'un
soutien budgétaire et bien l'Union
européenne demanderait à ces pays une
coopération économique mais bien sûr
aussi migratoire alors avant ce sommet
l'Union européenne espérait passer ce
genre d'accord avec la Tunisie mais pour
le moment le président tunisien estime
que son pays ne doit pas être ne doit
pas devenir le garde frontière de
l'Union européenne et puis certains pays
européens s'inquiète également de la
dérive autocratique de ce pays et bien
sûr de la question des droits de l'homme
merci beaucoup Alex